- I have to say, congrats.
You were just inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
- I know.
(audience cheers)
- I wanna see, can I see it?
- I know.
I brought this for the show.
This is my Rock and Roll
and I just wanna share this
with you until you get your own,
and you will.
- Oh, I will not, but I love you.
- You will, you will, you will.
- You are so,
I think you have to,
well it's funny, I was
literally talking to
my producer this morning and I was like,
we throw around the word icon a lot.
Like I feel like everybody's an icon now.
Like, you know, everybody's
like, oh, she's an icon.
I'm like, no, you have to earn that.
And you actually earned that.
And it's like you, that's
why I loved your response.
I loved your response 'cause
you were like, well wait what?
Rock and roll?
Like, I'm country music.
But you are rock and roll.
The fact that you're a pioneer for women,
you've opened the doors for so many of us
to be able to be
vulnerable as songwriters.
But I don't know, does it make,
does it weird you out
to be labeled an icon?
Does it, is it?
- Well, I always think of
myself more as an eyesore
than an icon.
- Well, I wish.
- Not actually, but you know,
I used to think when I was young,
if I made it like I'd hoped I would,
how people would remember
me when I was older.
Now I'm older, and it's
really nice to look back
and think that, you know,
I might have done something
that's helped inspire.
- Oh my God, so many things.
- You know, some other people.
And when I got into the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
or when they talked about that,
I didn't realize that it was,
it was more than just that.
To me, I'd always thought
about the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame being for
people that spend their life
in rock music, like country music.
I mean, you don't see Led Zeppelin
in the Country Music Hall of Fame.
You know, so I, when they first said that,
I thought, well, you know, I
don't know that I belong there
and I didn't wanna take
votes from other people
that spent their life.
And that's kinda how I felt.
- [Kelly] That is so Dolly.
Who says that?
- [Dolly] But still, I
honestly thought that,
but then later I saw that
it was for people also
that have, you know,
influenced other people.
And I did say I would accept
it gracefully and humbly,
and I did.
And I was very honored.
But-
- But you did something even cooler.
You actually wrote like
a rock and roll song.
- I did.
I wrote a song for the show
about my whole experience about that.
It's called, I've been,
it's called Rocking It.
'Cause I've been rocking it.
I grew up lovin' Elvis and,
wild man Jerry Lee, Chuck
Berry, Little Richard,
they had all cast a spell on me,
and Carl Perkins and them Blue Suede Shoes
had no place on the farm.
There's better than them Brogans
I was wearing around the barn.
So I've been rocking, rocking, rocking
since the day I was born.
I'll be rocking till the day I'm gone.
'Cause I've got rock and
roll down in my country soul
and I'll be rocking it
till the cows come home.
(audience cheers)
- That's so perfect.
- I go ahead and I talk
about the whole thing.
How, you know, how they, you know,
they put me in the hall of fame
so I guess it ain't no shame where I said,
you know but since I heard the big news,
I ain't never been the same.
'Cause they done gone and put me in
the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame, it's the dangdest thing.
But I was honored, and I'm proud. So.
- Yeah. And it's so cool
though, how, how you do,
you're so respectful of other artists,
and all their hard work,
but at the same time you're like,
'cause you're doing an album
now, like a rock album.
- I'm doin' a rock album.
I'm callin' it Rockstar.
Rockstar.
- I love it.
- A fun, tongue in cheek.
But I'm actually,
I'm doing classic songs and I'm usin'
a lot of the classic artists too,
to sing on some of the songs with me.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So I'm looking forward to that.
So that's gonna come out next year.